hello and welcome to video playing tap
chest with black I have played him
before don't quite remember the game was
it with the same opening possible oh
okay
don't see that too often d5 o 95 95 mm
d5 certainly also fairly fairly sounded
I mean why not
okay I can take care it take on your six
cents
I wonder if I take it
Luke shakes we should be six Queen B 5 C
6 is OK development expects a little bit
of audience if I'm not getting
checkmated immediately I'm going to be
quite happy with my pair of bishops I
could have gone d5 that is fairly short
okay but risky it's a bit risky in my
plane
yeah it was certainly also quite
possible so c6 yeah here I was thinking
I would definitely get an important
tempo with a move like 26 or winter
f6f-3 tf6 is not a full-time forward so
let's do it
26 oh okay
after Crete rate here I'm fairly certain
that I'm not worse which wasn't totally
clear to me because of the because of
the development issues f6 Knight f6 is
maybe an idea
why why does okay of course he says he
has such a good development that
something like rook d1 he will always be
able to probably get rid of one of my
bishops so that he equalizes
if it gets enormous time I grew create
we should be 7 and so on yeah and I
might be able to play for something yeah
here two chicks on the sixth second
takes it to
ouch
yeah that is a way to lose a game like
that just blunder idiotic claim I mean
I'm not losing straightaway but I didn't
see the move
young
this is why is not losing but it's of
course entirely unnecessary to get to
this position
let's see um got three against two so
maybe I can get the pawns rolling
yeah I'm trying to get see - I mean he
will have the the kingside that will
march forward I'm not really certain how
this should be assessed to be honest but
it wasn't it was necessary to get there
this is my main main issue
hmm I feel like I'm rather quick there
okay so if I go to a six now
how does he stop that
I don't see how
just promoting this thing mate yeah
there was quite weird the whole thing I
completely miss Bishop d7 so um yeah
played the knight c6 line the Marais
variation Knight takes e5 is not very
calm down I don't really know the theory
I'm just playing this and make things up
as I go along not c5 yeah and I cannot
be bad the sixes
could be risky yeah the engine gives d5
which which looks very sound yeah just
you five maybe six looks fine and this
is maybe dangerous and I'm really not
having much developed but least that it
who's the engine is not seeing anything
drastically bad about what I'm doing
yeah I'd have to be sure before I should
be okay but it seems that I'm not in
trouble here anyway anyhow you know aged
six here the only question is that can
black be better with the bishops but
somehow
white OS s is a group t1
okay six Mok Ji Won and yeah night 96
and now he played this yeah you create I
was thinking a moment there because I
saw that rook g8 is possible but I
didn't see that I didn't see anything
that I can do to play for win but I have
to be honest I didn't see actually that
I'm attacking g2 here but the engine
still gives equal was the through q4 I
have three l3 Bishop James T 2 equal
yeah ok
it's so better than what I did when I
was thinking this is unclear but where
was the blunder it says I made one
blunder I mean of course I'm not playing
this perfectly but I'm not sure where
the blunder actually occurs anyway now
I'm getting this rolling blitz it's a
bit of a gamble here you cannot really
assess this this properly I felt I'm
okay because my my bishop and the b-pawn
will work together quite well but it's
ultimately difficult to figure out with
no time the engine just says I'm winning
I wasn't entirely certain okay King this
King b7 was a mistake
yeah I didn't have much time of course
but still does that 96 I overlooked okay
back back on track it was it wasn't
it's difficult had no time letting the
clock run down and the increment is nice
to have but you cannot really find
brilliant concepts with with this time
control ok guys thanks for watching